bonjour nicolas vidal merci d'être avec
nous sur un jour hier tu es france alors
on le disait en plus de 3000 nouveaux
quatre connards coronavirus ont été
enregistrés ces dernières 24 heures
comment interpréter ces derniers
chiffres et faut-il s'inquiéter de la
situation en france c'est compliqué
cette situation peut vite parce que le
gouvernement on va en parler avec leur
conseiller du ministre je vous
finalement sur des espèces
d'alternatives très compliqué je matin
jean castex ne comprend la france
interdisait qu'on pouvait aller au
théâtre au cinéma faire comme bon nous
semble et il fallait rester prudent vous
savez donc concrètement aujourd'hui
c'est très très compliqué d'avoir une
vision très claire et gouvernement
d'ailleurs aucune vision claire on le
voit tous
on discute on parlemente on voit les
masques pas les masques d'ailleurs on
peut en parler regardez aujourd'hui il
ya eu deux semaines de vacances au
gouvernement était relié çà et là
d'ailleurs c'est marrant parce qu'on
leur a demandé au ministre de patassé
l'espace schengen donc on arrive
toujours à l'union européenne est
finalement tous ces gens sont partis
deux semaines en vacances
et aujourd'hui on consulte d'après ce
que dit gabriel atteint il ya des
consultations qui sont faites avec les
divers brancher les différents secteurs
les professionnels les entreprises des
écoles et finalement la rentrée
professionnelle et éducatives et lundi
1er septembre
comment aujourd'hui penser qu' on essaie
de discuter de palabrer cette semaine là
alors que la grosse rentrée c'est lundi
on voit bien qu'à un moment donné il ya
une impréparation qui manifeste qui
préside cette crise du corona des rues
depuis le début c'est très compliqué et
très sûrement à comprendre c'est la
confusion la plus totale encore même
pression que ce gouvernement navigue à
vue en permanence et justement jean
castex a détaillé ce matin la feuille de
route du gouvernement pour appréhender
cette rentrée comme vous l'avait dit et
qui est dans moins d'une semaine
est-ce que c'est désormais l'heure de
vérité pour lui deux mois après sa
nomination surprise au poste de premier
ministre à son quelles vont être les
prochains défis pour jean castex
il ya trois défis de le premier la crise
sanitaire le kovy 19 ça il va falloir
voir comment ils vont agences et ça il
va y avoir une déclaration je crois
d'ici quelques heures de noël après
demain il ya le front de l'emploi avec
la crise la crise sociale la crise
économique qui va être terrible et puis
ensuite à l'insécurité
cette bombe sécuritaires et identitaires
qui est absolument l'angle mort des
manuels macron depuis le début et on
al'impression on verra si emmanuel
macron
le problème à bras le corps mais
apparemment ils vont séminaristes et
donc en fait alors que la france
s'engouffrant dans une espèce de crise
absolue nous enfin le gouvernement
pardon séminaristes consulte donc la
crise du coc vide on ne comprend pas
très bien on entretient depuis plusieurs
mois une chape de peur terrorisante
nantes paris et marseille et finalement
jean castex que ça c'est mon aller au
théâtre aller au cinéma ça ça va être
compliqué puis une nouvelle fois les
mesures sont extrêmement contestée il
suffit d'avoir les responsables des
syndicats par étudiant mais de
l'éducation nationale qui sont vent
debout contre les réformes fin contre
les mesures pardon qui vont être apposés
des 1er septembre vraiment je le répète
on navigue à vue dans cette crise là et
nous sommes le 26 août il est 14h07
on rentre le 1er septembre ou le 2
septembre et aujourd'hui il n'y a aucune
rue aucune mention claire aucune
procédure aux sanitaires très claire sur
ce qui va advenir dès la semaine
prochaine que ce soit dans les écoles
david est que ce soit dans les
entreprises c'est sait vraiment si
consternant
voilà c'est consternant c'est quoi c'est
dû à quoi c'est dû à un manque de prise
de conscience de la part du gouvernement
on l'a entendu en plusieurs fois sur
notre antenne les français attendent que
le gouvernement passent des paroles aux
actes très rapidement avec la rentrée
scolaire qui approche à grands pas vous
l'avez dit et comment se porte la
confiance des français envers l'exécutif
à bien vous savez il ya eu l'histoire
des masques à l'histoire des votes pour
moi c'est symptomatique sans mauvais jeu
de mot pardon si ça prend la tournure
d'une série télé qui nourrit le
gouvernement voit là et je le dis
sincèrement je pense que l'histoire des
masques de cette crise ducobu 19 a
énormément écornée entaché la parole les
utilisaient d'abord le politique et d'un
certain membre du conseil médical ça
c'est extrêmement important après le
problème il ya la relance sanitaire la
relance économique
là on se trouve dans une contradiction
absolument effroyable il ya un plan de
relance qui va être annoncé d'ailleurs
au passage il a été repoussé un on ne
sait pas pourquoi ça a été repoussée bon
c'est comme ça ça devait être annoncé
maintenant étudier ce sera 3 septembre
parce que finalement la commission
européenne aussi est en vacances depuis
depuis mi-août donc il va falloir on
n'arrive pas à voir ces gens téléphonent
pour arriver à mettre en place a
peaufiné je vais prendre langage
technocratique à peaufiner ce plan de
relance qui me semble aujourd'hui je
vais être très intéressés à le
décortiquer ce plan de relance donc
finalement pour répondre à votre
question david ya 7 e il ya cette
dualité cette ambivalence entre la
relance
la crise sanitaire et la relance
économique parce que tous les deux
bon de père aimait sur la crise
sanitaire on espère aussi au passage qui
aura une relance démocratique dès la
semaine prochaine alors selon jean
castex vous venez de l'évoquer un ce
plan de relance est bouclé les 200
milliards d'euros pourquoi attendre
finalement que ce plan de relance se met
en place et surtout la question qui va
se poser pour la plupart des français
sait comment ce plan de relance va être
financé ce qu'il faut s'inquiéter d'un
impôt supplémentaire dans les années qui
viennent alors bruno le maire nous a dit
qu'il n'y aurait pas d'impôt
supplémentaire mais vous ne le maire
nous a aussi dit ce cher bruno le maire
nous a dit qu'il fallait que les
français dépensent eh bien les français
peuvent pas dépenser
monsieur mise de l'économie c'est une
première chose les jo remet en
perspective le plan de relance david
il faut revenir à l'accord du 21 juillet
2020 emmanuel macron avec le lac l'union
européenne ça c'est extrêmement
important il faut savoir que cet accord
qui a été fait qui est historique
peut-être mais qui paye historique pour
la france parce que ça va obliger la
france à continuer à proroger les des
réformes structurelles vous savez la
réforme des retraites doivent bien sûr
un chômage et ça c'est extrêmement
important parce que je pense très
sincèrement qu'il a été il a été décalé
ce plan de relance parce qu'il faut
s'entendre aussi avec l'union européenne
et savoir parce qu'on va avoir des
contreparties on peut pas croire que et
puis c'est notre argent aussi qu'il va
être investi là-dedans c'est pas
l'argent du gouvernement c'est l'état
c'est nous donc je pense que le décalage
du plan de relance au site qui se fera
forcément avec l'accord de la commission
européenne easa secteur important parce
qu'on nous dit qu'à retenir d'euros et
puis gelé en peluche bien entendu et
comme nous tous les journalistes
éditeurs ex politique 40 milliards
d'euros pour l'industrie 30 milliards
d'euros pour l'écologie enfin tout ça ce
sont des grands chiffres et on va
attendre avec beaucoup de précision
savoir ce qui va être mis où ça va être
mis à quel degré ça va être mis les voir
aussi contradiction parce que je le dis
souvent sur votre antenne david on ne
peut pas faire de l'écologie qu'on a
traitées qu'on a signé 46 traité de
libre échange
le dernier en date c'est le c'est à
singapour et voilà donc ça c'est des
choses aujourd'hui on est en pleine
contradiction et ce conseil des
ministres ce matin une nouvelle fois
c'est la contradiction ça a été emballé
par gabriel atteint dans un langage
technocratique vie des indigents ou un
appareil de benchmark notamment sur la
gestion des masses par les autres pays
européens
voilà on continue dans cette crise et je
pense que ça va être ça va être très
très compliqué parce que vous savez les
français aujourd'hui
porte plus la confusion et l'incohérence
des situations qui aujourd'hui régis
aussi leurs libertés publiques ça sera
le mot de la fin merci beaucoup nicolas
vidal d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes directeur de
publier de publication du magazine coach